So get this--
Belinda is saying she has
fibromyalgia yet again,
which means that
I have to cover
the Houston conference.
That is
so awesome, babe.
(Amy Schumer)
It can happen anytime.
Oh, my God.
You're not even
listening to me.
Now, help is
at your fingertips.
Hello?
ListenAlert,
this is Katie. Just stay calm
and tell me your story.
Oh, thank God. Okay, so I talked to HR
and apparently,
I have to go to Houston
and I wanted to fly JetBlue,
but they're making me
go on Southwest.
Here at ListenAlert, our trained
operators are standing by,
waiting to respond
to your calls,
to hear how things turned out.
We're prepared
with such phrases as,
"Are you kidding me?"
Or, "Uh-huh."
Or, "She's the worst.
Sounds like you handled that
perfectly."
Technically, I haven't
lost any weight yet,
but I feel lighter.
Oh, my God,
you guys.
I totally forgot.
I saw Janelle
yesterday.
Oh, my God.
What was she wearing?
(inhales, then exhales)
ListenAlert, this is Jeff,
tell me everything.
Don't leave out
your feelings.
I'm on my third day
of green juice,
but since I'm having a salad
tonight, I think it's okay.
You should have
a podcast.
ListenAlert is not just
for women.
So when I started high school,
I was 5'10", 150 pounds,
then in my junior year,
I shot up to like 6'2",
buck-ninety.
But what size shoe
did you wear?
Well, that's the thing.
Like I had always
had size 13s,
so I was just kind
of waiting to grow.
In the cases
of longer stories,
we'll even dispatch our agents
right to you.
So there is another clutch
that was 50% off,
but it was
a little smaller, like...
Is it more like
a wristlet?
I'm having trouble
picturing the size.
Help is on the way.
(phone beeps)
Were they buy one, get one
or buy one, get one 50% off?
It was 50% off, but it was
only in one color.
Which color?
Red.
That's a tough one.
All this is covered by a low,
low price of $100,000 a month.
So it was like
my grandma's house,
but at the same time,
it was not totally
my grandma's house, like--
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba!
We are not saints.
♪ ListenAlert
we will not listen to dreams ♪